hey what's up I'm Maddie I'm Jonathan
I'm supposed to say your character name
I know uh chase and I play John B hi I'm
Rudy Paul can I play JJ Madison Bailey
and I play keaur I'm Sarah anything
right like I could you know what you're
right yeah like everybody everybody we
should all just point to ourselves here
yeah you know what you know what you're
welcome I've been known to take the
timestamp off of my pink drink I was
like traffic there it wasn't fast in the
drive-through oh really the bag of
cheese it's one of the two it's fruit
snacks you know what I would eat them
all before we started shooting I would
decide now somehow he put down six bags
oh wait
a case he always he's always the last
yeah I'll take anymore is just like
shorts and a t-shirt is in like black
eyes I look at these locks they don't
just like come out oh no actually I
think JD would be the one that pulled
prank cuz you'd always be like oh he had
a good one with this stunt yeah oh yeah
I had to get our stuff courted her back
cuz he did something to me cuz I put a
hole in the wall that's a different
story we were shooting a stunt and in
the stunt it's like a very intense like
see and like we choreographed it and
they were they weren't very they weren't
very okay with letting like they were
okay with letting me like do a starting
like hit cuz he doesn't go golf club hit
on me and I kind of let him like get me
a little bit and I like hit you got I
don't lose and I'm like my back my back
dude pretty ready I make up my own mind
this I'm gonna I'm gonna go ahead and
throw myself under the bus he is like a
human dictionary for our entire season
and I would just care midsi and I'd be
like what am I supposed to say he says a
lot Wow really maybe an alien for sure
yeah yeah she should kill it she'll kill
him it's not a normal week if I don't
get at least 2 DM dreams from this
person yeah yeah I said to everybody the
spongebob memes are like they work for
everything they just really good I like
that I really like that made of Idris
Elba on hot ones what he's like but it's
not like on set it's like no airs change
is definitely changing cuz trailer
naw I remember one night one night chase
that we filmed pretty late at night and
one night chase like was supposed to go
home and he he's like oh this now how
long me hello me there to like 3 a oh
yeah it was like 7 o'clock daily like
they're like baby baby yeah JD got a
wrap gift and it was bracelets and it
said jokes for life on it but he spelt
Polk's is P ow
okay I made it past was last minute and
I did not tell the feel you g KW z RS no
no it's not
I've talked about a lot of a sanitation
ladies super neutral I'd say he's the
most neutral atom every very well ya
know YouTube YouTube because he kept
singing rich girl by Hollow notes on
send it's stuck in my head I would also
sing Christmas music sporadically
throughout the summer she's glamorous
y'all are welcome is dangerous what
what's that discovery show it's making
it afraid should do that we're going to
show up completely naked sitting in the
truck but not afraid I'm never afraid I
have so many videos but not just him
doing impressions of us like it's like a
what 12 minute video of you doing a
Morgan Freeman impression over there
crab farming crime like you would do it
like march of the Penguins with crabs
hello there you're listening to the
sweet silky silvery voice of Morgan
Freeman today we're going to be
discussing superlatives why in high
school I was voted most likely to
narrate your life six years old my voice
dropped
[Music]
[Music]